[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we have a first
here at cinemasins
I'm knocking off a sin for the
combination of Disney and Pixar logos
being a blessedly brief ten seconds
which means this is the first film ever
to start off with negative sins
mind blown hey wait a minute why is the
M so hard to eat this monster ate the
other M just fine and since when did
letters become sentient beings like
right before the L in film was eaten now
wait a minute the soccer ball was
clearly under the bed in the previous
shot the skateboard would have made more
sense now the skateboard isn't even here
hello the toy racetrack isn't even here
and definitely not a half play game of
jacks evil guy is evil because
everything about his character design
and introduction lighting tells me he's
evil no you nerd because we need this
boss wastes natural resources just to
demonstrate what the natural resources
are also how did monsters ever figure
out that screams power thinks how did
they first collect it and this seems
like something you should have an
abundance of what with wav files and
digital copies and whatnot weird monster
penis painting car with teeth inspires
the two worst Pixar movies ever now to
the world was also drawn using
children's screams it seems like Sulley
is so good at this
he should easily be able to work a
little overtime and help get the city's
supply of scream back up to normal
levels I mean how long does it take to
get the screen like a minute
if you extrapolated that over a typical
eight-hour shift she'll be able to get
the city's power back in no time I don't
understand dating in the monster world
Mikey apparently is a completely
different species with no discernible
genitalia Mike leaves himself three
poster reminders to file his paperwork
but if the first two reminders didn't
help it's kind of a sin that he'd think
the third one would I'll tell you what's
really creepy is how they got this kid's
picture to put the five also monsters
ink spells yield wrong that's true for
the corporation and the movie movie rips
off the slow motion walking sequence
from all the movies ice that fall out
this easily or maybe not so ready to be
eyes this scene where they realized that
girl is too won't be scared and they
call for the dead door demolition team
makes me wonder how did they get the
doors for newborn kits where do they
come from who builds them or creates
them here in Monster Wyatt how do I even
know of a new human child's existence
these days they just don't get scared
like they used to share kids were
exposed to more things even back in 2001
I find it hard to believe there's so
much more used to scary things that
actual monsters coming in the rooms
don't bother them cute design on this
monster with the hard hat and little eye
tentacle holes but doesn't that negate
some of the hard hats effectiveness when
something could fall and smash into his
eyes clearly no sock on this guy's back
as he struts out of the kids room but
then suddenly a sock shows up like magic
when he starts walking forward monster
cup sizes range from two ounce to twenty
ounce to 115 ounce and that's it
you either drink hardly enough the
perfect amount or way too much hey can I
borrow your rodent in this world where
we've seen too toothbrushing scenes
Monsters Inc wants to have it both ways
and be the opposite of the human world
for just this one joke I know we're
dicks this is a cute moment but the
movie literally hinges entirely on the
notion that Sully is somehow incapable
of putting this child inside her room
and closing the door before she slips
back out Randall just happens to be
implementing a secret evil plan on the
very night Sully stayed behind to cover
Mikey's paperwork also didn't everybody
just get off work why has Randall so
dumb as to do his shady scaring like
five minutes after quitting time how
fast is it even physically possible for
a workplace this large to empty out okay
come on first we didn't see boo at all
during the entire last 30 seconds of
panic by Sully second of all he
seriously can't feel some toddler size
thing hanging off his back with all this
stuff we just watched it's amazing the
timing of Randall's exit from the
bedroom
just one second and more sooner than
he'd have busted Sully running through
the floor with a child in the bag also
this is Boo's door and she's not in
there
so what the hell was Randall doing all
this time while Sully was running around
the locker room we learned later he
wanted to kidnap her so was he just
chilling and waiting where did he
assumed she'd gone how did he know when
to stop chilling and waiting why is the
system built in such a way that one
cannot quickly recall a door that's been
sent away recently that seems like a
really stupid design flaw plot-related
designs law but still it wouldn't that
to get your paperwork and there was a
door what she can't hear them
Sulli freaks out over food touching him
when she's touched him a million times
already you think he's gonna come
through the closet and scare you they
set this kid up so it appeared she
wasn't scared of anything but she
apparently really is scared of Randle so
why was she so unafraid of Sully when he
walked through the door man think about
what her parents are going through right
now if you think about this movie from
their perspective it gets a lot more
lovely bones than you wanted to um the
candles are still burning geez
Hollywood has terrible flame discipline
good thing monsters have both the same
physiology and toilet fixtures as humans
Randall's worker but he openly discusses
the kid he's ultimately responsible for
inside a public restroom
Jeff fungus ex machina super observant
monster is momentarily super unobservant
for comedy sake toilet paper sticks to
your heel after using the bathroom
cliche although when I think about it
how they were in the cleanest bathroom
in the history of bathrooms see for the
upcoming company played called that put
that thing back where it came from or so
help me Mike and Sully's co-workers
believe this
Celia shows up out of nowhere so that
she can yell at Mikey and Randall can
figure out that they were at the sushi
place last night the articles on this
newspaper are the biggest bunch of
nonsense we've ever seen here at cinema
sits and that's saying something
the writer even bothered to write ohms
and oz in this thing sure it could be a
joke but what's not a joke is somebody
was able to snap this photo of boo while
she rampaged the sushi restaurant I know
you want to keep giving Randall reasons
to use his abilities but Mike had a huge
head start here and didn't even know
himself where he was running so this
book is impossible it's 11:55 a.m. right
now and a mere two minutes ago with no
significant passage of time whatsoever
it was 8:50 now normally this would be a
really stupid nitpick that has nothing
to do with the quality of the movie and
in all fairness it still doesn't and a
ton of you will try to think the worst
thing ever commented on YouTube ever
because of it but in this case it's
important because the next plot
development entirely hinges on the scare
floor going to lunch in five minutes how
are they going to lunch when they just
got here kid has been wandering free and
Monsters Inc without one monster seeing
see da assholes appear so you'll think
Sully's in trouble but then become
fanboys which also allows boo - once
again avoid capture these CDA guys were
all going number two at the same time
[Music]
[Applause]
that's weird because the last time Bumi
the lights go out it was because she was
crying not laughing
she's been laughing the whole damn time
she's been in this building and nothing
happened Randall actually thinks Mikey
is boo for some reason why does Randall
ever bother becoming visible why not
stay invisible and search the entire
floor before revealing yourself
Randall manages to increase his distance
between he and Sully despite Sully
running and Randall going the exact same
speed out of nowhere and super
conveniently discovered secret door
isn't travel proof look this door closes
on its own but also somehow knows to
wait until after you hesitate then
finally enter the tunnel Jesus you had
no problem carrying the crate earlier
when you're first kidnapped Mikey so why
is this any different and what do
monsters no less yeah so this scream
extractor sounds evil but the only
reason is that they're going to have to
kidnap kids but why do they need to do
that why not bring the machine to the
scare floor or make it smaller for
Christ's sake
what's different about this machine
that's any more unethical with and
running in and scaring little kids for
their screams furthermore Randall's
actions on the night boo came over to
the monster world don't really make
sense now if the whole reason he set the
door up that night was to kidnap boo
then why didn't he just take her instead
of stopping Midway to get some scream
tubes didn't he have plenty near the
secret door
for the secret evil lab where he's
testing this machine out scream
extractor is plugged into a place where
it is easily unplugged without detection
person who has something really
important to say is constantly
interrupted by interrupting douchebag
cliche yeah so why isn't this kid's fake
recorded screams worth some scream
energy you can its midi-chlorians isn't
it I was just recording of Sully scare
just happens to be rewound and paused on
the perfect spot and contains all the
important story information
Oh banished to the human world so
naturally the first thing they bump into
is a monster from their own world
snowcone don't worry it's lemon monster
seeing shows it has the bravery to
insert a much needed pee joke into the
script wasteland I think you mean
Wonderland marketing Sully's sudden
violent outburst leads to the very
answer to the problem he was just out
bursting about doesn't that matter so
Lee says nothing because he knows the
movie needs all the wrong time it can
get
[Music]
dammit Randy Newman that music is almost
exactly the same piece of music you did
in the natural you didn't think I'd
notice did you luckily at this exact
moment kids are being scared by monsters
right now they hadn't started doing this
yet celebrated got what he deserves
Sullivan was twice the scarer you will
ever be both conflict between two
villains intended to distract and buy
time for the hero cliche is bullshit
Sully doesn't remember how easy this
secret door is to open mic Sully had a
huge head start and all the kids in the
entire village were already being scared
not to mention the security breach the
company just endured with Sully showing
up out of nowhere so how the hell did
make it get here so fast
Mike you don't understand yes I do
Monsters Inc goes back to the
interrupting douchebag well let me or
ten minutes after doing it the first
time Mikey throws a snowball that should
clearly be melted by now and
miraculously hits Randall with it damn
doesn't she have a job as a receptionist
why is she spending so much time in the
hallways no one on the work floor hits
the all stop button on this door machine
or wait are you saying there is no all
stop button for this thing you spawn
started zero planning ahead when
building this Factory it's weird how
many Pixar movies end up in a giant
factory of some sort where the heroes
have to navigate unthinking and
unfeeling machinery there was no reason
whatsoever for this door storage
facility track to be laid out like a
theme park ride these door all by itself
so it can be easily identified I still
contend this is total nonsense after her
crying cost the blackout before also
doors somehow could get powered up
without all this stuff from the scare
floor which makes everything nice and
tidy and convenient for this adventure
Mikey and Sulley managed to find another
kids closet door in the very next beach
house they run into 10 kabillion doors
in here and you manage to leave and
return within two rows of boos door each
time do you a movie why doesn't Randall
just camp out in front of boos dorm
there's no need to chase these guys
through out the door warehouse is there
we lost them god damn it
what it's amazing in this giant place
anything Sully is looking for can be
found within seconds naturally some of
these door factory tracks move faster
than others because suddenly needed to
catch up to Randall Randall gives us a
perfect example of monologuing three
years before the Incredibles even coined
the phrase yeah there's definitely time
for this
meanwhile booze parents have had the
neighbor kid thrown in jail and
suspicion of kidnapping but hey baseball
everyone
yep that's Nemo and that's the Pizza
Planet truck yep you're observant Paul
you want a cookie go start a YouTube
channel and do it consistently
wait there's a kid's closet door in this
trailer also unluckily for the heroes
they threw Randall into a place where he
would immediately get his comeuppance
and he couldn't just do exactly what
they did to get back and while we're on
the subject when a Bigfoot and the
abominable snowman do the same thing and
just come home to Monstropolis and the
doorman's in the station cut the power
you'll have the child and the criminals
responsible for this whole mess how does
he know that he's a character in the
movie he's not watching all the Bulls we
just watched right right no one sees
these fingers every CDA person and water
news fall for this and run away from the
door this is an accident but as it turns
out totally necessary to the plan to
expose water News's evil plot the rest
of you guys but this is exactly what our
intern Kyle says every time we watch a
movie and this is why he doesn't get to
write sins with us it's because of your
attitude Kyle I wish instead you're not
gonna believe this we actually get a
prequel in about ten years it took you
two and a half years to figure out what
was going on here and why were you
investigating them the first place there
wasn't anything shady going on until
recently if the movie I just want it to
be believed especially with the shortage
of screen that this very movie's plot is
contingent upon wouldn't an abundance of
screen be cause for alarm I realize I'm
more prone in the average bearer to
notice stuff like this but the
deliberateness of this old lady sweater
boobs is making me uncomfortable
no cops or parents of this girl who has
been missing for a really long time or
in this room or even close enough to
hear the commotion in this room no look
Jessie from Toy Story 2 and the bouncy
ball
this is back in the time when Pixar
actually wanted you to notice their
easter eggs
oh yeah and Finding Nemo again this
child should still be screaming bloody
murder right now so the movie ends with
the positive note that they can merely
get kids laughs to power the city but
I'm guessing the idea of a monster
coming into your bedroom to do stand-up
is still pretty scary and you're gonna
have a way harder time getting those
laughs then you dip those scares even if
they are 10 times more powerful which is
convenient as hell by the way so the
first rule of comedy is punch line does
not mean hit the child this is the first
rule and it's not only not going to
improve anyone's comedy it's actually
about preventing child abuse which is an
amazing cause but one I hope these folks
already support Gallagher monster you
know it only works if you have every
piece which means this whole thing is
impossible but whatever happy ending is
at least an ending okay damn it
I'm not made of stone that's worth a
since attraction Dannan and while that
definitely deserves a since subtraction
is Sully just gonna keep visiting boo
throughout the years cuz boo go crazy
trying to tell people she has a monster
who comes by every night and makes her
laugh that she could tired of and
visiting when she's a teenager
does it become like the Toy Story series
when the kid finally has to put away
childish things and become an adult
happy ending with lots of questions
there
[Music]
I have to dribble if I give it to you
you just shoot your a chucker Chuck
that's right every time you get the ball
you shoot be the best monster win
I plan to they look like good strong
hands don't they
what's this what's this let's watch my
favorite part again get your ass the
boss but get your ass to Mars but imma
get your ass to Mars but get your ass to
Mars but get your ass to Mars